on the hill today for the giants will be
the veteran right-hander kevin gausman
kevin gausman in his seventh year at the
big league level he's 29 years of age
got him three pitches ooh and
reach back speed at 97 miles per hour
got him high fastball ends the inning
and the threat
chi-chi gonzalez on the bound for the
rockies trying to make a good
final impression second and third nobody
out here is wilmer flores
the pitch on the way swing and a line
drive base hit
right through the hole into right field
coming into score is slater
so flores breaks as russ hodges used to
say
breaks off to schneid with a base hit to
right his first hit in his last 17
at bats one to nothing giants
here's crawford crawford doesn't have a
hit in the series but he
had a big sacrifice fly in the game last
night
driven to right blackman's not going to
get it it bounces up against archway
number four
dickerson scores and putting on the
brakes is flores
and crawford knocks in a run it's
two-nothing
take a look at the location i mean
that's
down and in right at the knee
[Music]
and he gets good power driving right
through that thing and
he had some top spin on that ball
this is hit on the ground floor is on
the backhand
he lobs one to first and they got him
and boy it's great having a guy
that's six foot nine over at first base
got about a six foot four inch umpire
too and he became a wall for ryan
mcmahon after the play
all right let's take a look at the
backhander from flores and
up goes belt and
phil who is 6'4 used every bit here's
dickerson with the bases loaded
five for six lifetime against chichi
gonzalez
in a way gets away from walters and
coming in to score
is joey bart so the table setters have
set it up for the big fellas
and you know what trevor's stories think
i can make this a new ball game
i could tie this bad boy up got him
now 98 sets up 87 with the same arm
action
and that's a big get for gazmin
you cannot execute a changeup better
than that strikeout number four
and that was perfection got him
and that'll end the inning and change up
away that'll bring up ryan mcmahon
next pitch swing and a fly ball to left
field dickerson moving back onto the
track
reaches up and he can't bring it in the
ball ricochets back towards the infield
and coming around third and scoring will
be
josh fuentes ryan mcmahon into second
base with an rbi
double and the rockies are on the board
they trail three to one
topia strikeout and he reached on a
fielder's choice
and this is a base hit to left tapia
coming through with two outs
one run game as mcmahon scores
rymel tapia with his 15th rbi
how many hits does he have to left for
you and this is big too
hit well to left field dubon on the move
dubon's going to reach up and he makes
the catch
and fuentes can't believe it
white fence white ball white uniform
and you couldn't tell a long fly ball
off the bat of josh fuentes he's
thinking it's time to trot
but not here and not with duvan who goes
up on the wall
i mean look at that athleticism how he
positioned himself awkwardly to get up
and make the play
charlie is single in the first strikeout
fly ball to left field since
back up the middle and this will get the
time run home
so charlie got it in play pilar scores
to tie it at three
rbi number 40. it's three to three we
start all over again
here in the seventh inning fuentes
center field
base hit fuentes rockies take the lead
man has he had some big knocks and in
particular with two outs of late
how many clutch hits has he come up with
time and time again he does and
mentioned about getting on top of a high
fastball this one wasn't quite as high
as more
belt high now the rocky's ahead 4-3
4-3 rockies given stays in he'll be
facing belt
belt hits a high fly ball to the left
tapia back gets started to carry
out of here
and this game is tied
home run number nine how about that
and that's career hit number one
thousand for belt up
unbelievable well he got a change up and
he got
under it positioned each outfielder in
the gaps
copy on left center hillard in right
center
both with excellent arms fuentes is at
third
and murphy's at first on the ground
story's got it he's gonna come home they
get the out
there what a game-saving play by
trevor story
and now the rockies have a nice little
advantage
because the runner at second is garrett
hampton who's one of the fastest guys at
baseball
one-two pitch in the air left field
backing up
dickerson he'll make the catch tagging
is hampson
he will score and the rockies are up
that's what the boys are doing up the
middle they're a couple steps back now
they might creep in as the pitch is
being delivered
and this is bounced to third there's one
on the first ball game over
rockies win it 5-4 how do you like that
tip of the cap to to buddy and the staff
and everybody the way they played this
game defensively
the last couple innings it played out
perfectly